Another question, my husband, is interested in the supplement of stamina, the shield,
shield you for supplement.
Some research on it suggests to avoid dairy, meat, sour, tasty, and citrus.
Should you eat these foods completely or only would take you the morning dose of stamina?
So is this a safe supplement for someone with a cancer diagnosis?
Let me look up everything that's in that again, remember off the top of my head.
So yeah, that is a safe supplement for anybody with a cancer diagnosis.
The only thing that you would want to be careful of is if you had a growling prostate cancer.
So if a person had a growling prostate cancer and they're on antigen deprivation therapy,
then they might want to reconsider that.
I would definitely want to test for that, at least that.
That would be the only downside, anyone who can take it, anybody else could take it.
It's only that somebody was going to have an active prostate cancer.
As far as studies at Shell researchers, you said that you should avoid dairy, meat, fish,
and sour, tasty, and citrus.
At the time you're taking that, I would just say 30 minutes away from that, if we would be fair.
Otherwise, you're fine.
Do I need to be careful of textures made of ethanol?
So that perhaps the ethanol comes from GMO cord sprayed with chemicals.
So there's a lot of textures on the market that are alcohol-based tinctures.
Alcohol-based tinctures are probably not going to be made with organic alcohol.
So then you do have the possibility of getting GMO ingredients in the alcohol.
We use organic vodka with all our tinctures.
But unless the tincture you're buying a store bought tincture,
even the ones that we sell at our store from other companies,
I don't know that they're all listed as organic.
So if it's not listed as organic, let me just look up one product.
And as I do so, here's the deadline route that we use a lot of from professional formulas.
And it's...
We don't have a picture of the back of the bottle.
So it don't know that it's listed as organic.
So there could possibly be the GMO ingredients in any of these alcohol-based tinctures.
The thing is, you're not getting very much of it.
So it's not like you're drinking a glass of...
People drink a glass of wine, or they're exposed to more GMOs than when to get a teaspoon of alcohol.
So I don't know how much.
I haven't looked at any studies.
I don't usually tell people not to be drinking, and I don't drink.
So I haven't really done much investigation of that.
I know what Anthony Ashley did with us, and it actually program different types of wine.
And I...
That's not my headache.
I remember the type of wine that was highly recommended in the research that they did.
But it was even better than just organic.
So do you have to worry about GMO ingredients in a tincture?
I would say no, because even in an organic product,
you're probably getting a greater number of GMO products in organic products.
So because of cross-contamination.
So you're only doing two teaspoons of a tincture or something like that.
You are probably not exposed to any more GMO ingredients that you are eating,
a meal of organic food at different times that may have cross-contaminated GMO things in it.
So that's just the world we live in.
It's so cross-contaminated, even the best things you do.
So again, I would have put a concern about it.
We're exposed to more things than what you can get in that GMO chemicals in that tincture.
Where do you find organic vodka?
We just get it at the local liquor store.
And I think with Vega, didn't we get some of Costco or something, too?
Can't remember.
But yeah, it's just, I can't remember the brand name.
Any Megan's on the call, maybe she can message me the brand name of that.
So yeah, it was just a regular liquor store, I think.
And by Cheek Club last week, you were reading No Dairy.
But you didn't mention whether I could continue low history foods and intraments and fasting.
Do you remember any of those results continuing to my diet suggestions?
Like Syrex, Syrex Array had basically shown that I was creating antibodies to basically everything.
I was eating even more histamine foods.
So I wasn't sure how strict I should be since the elimination diet didn't work too well on my GI issues.
Though I would just say you're creating a lot more inflammatory cytokines by eating foods that you
have antibodies against than you are in eating histamine foods.
So I would just try to stay towards that Syrex 10 Array as best you can
and introducing new foods and make sure that your tummy can handle them.
That not be as concerned with the histamine issues.
As far as, as far as,
maybe fasting, maybe key type diets and doing intermittent fasting, I don't test for that or say.
So there's a little way to physiological tests for that.
Is that good for everybody to do that?
Yes, it can be good for everybody to do that on it.
And her basic doesn't mean, again, like I said before,
does it mean you have to do that on a daily, weekly basis?
No, but to do that on a variable basis can be beneficial.
Maybe you do it once or twice a week.
Maybe you do it once or twice a week and only every other week doing it that way.
So that would, with intermittent fasting, is the way to go.
Plus, again, you don't do intermittent fasting if you're in a weight loss perspective.
You're losing weight and trying to gain weight, you don't do that.
So the brand of that organic vodka was prairie farms.
And it was available at the hospital.
I do think we saw that.
We did get that at a regular liquor store as well.
But I know we got a bigger bottle at the hospital.